you
hello and welcome to Android developer
office hours for Wednesday October 24
2012 for those of you joining us this
week this is the show or for the first
time this week this is the show where we
normally answer questions live from
developers via hangout and we're still
doing to do that at the end we're gonna
try something a little different this
week we have a pre-recorded set of
questions or pre-recorded question weird
answer I've been a depth before we get
started so sit back enjoy the show and
will resume the live broadcast
afterwards and take any hangout
questions at the time play the video
hello and welcome to dear Android the
show previously known as Android
developer office hours we got a bit
tired of developers always trying to
show us up by asking us questions we
couldn't answer every week so we just
try to decided to try new format for a
change we'll be selecting the best
android application development
questions from across the Internet
including Google Plus and answer them
for you here on youtube if you're
watching us live which is every
wednesday 2 p.m. pacific will be hanging
around for a few minutes after each
episode to answer any questions about
this about the current episode so with
that other way let's go ahead and move
on to this week's question which comes
from Dancia on Stack Overflow whose user
from Poland he asks if I have a custom
service that I'm broadcasting via
bonjour and that I'd like to either you
know broadcast or discover using Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth is this possible on Android
to answer this question we have Alex
Lucas who's a member of our Android
developer relations team who wrote many
of the doctrine of the docs about both
network service discovery and Wi-Fi on
our developer site Alex could you help
us answer this question absolutely so to
break the question in into two subparts
will bonjour like services work on
Bluetooth and all they work on Wi-Fi the
answer is yes on Wi-Fi no one bluetooth
thank you for tuning in that's our show
see Alex bye so we should actually
probably answer this question in a
little bit more detail but to start with
the Bluetooth part Bluetooth is a really
great protocol for lots of device to
device applications like streaming music
or org communicating with heart rate
monitors but on Android it does not
actually support TCP so what that means
is you cannot create a TCP socket and
connect to it over Bluetooth to other
devices because network service
discovery or at least the Android
implementation of network service
discovery run over TCP this creates a
fundamental incompatibility between
Bluetooth and tcp that said it does
actually work over Wi-Fi
alright so before we go into a bit more
detail let's give it a bit of background
about what exactly n SD is so n st is
network service discovery which is
androids implementation of multicast dns
using the dns SD dns service discovery
protocol and what this does is it allows
applications to broadcast to their
existence on the local network along
with connection details for that
application to any other devices in the
same proximity which would be any other
devices again on the same local network
so this is useful for things like social
applications games or even network
services like printers or web servers so
that's way you can find out what devices
are nearby when MSD broadcasts this
information over the network there's
four fundamental pieces of information
it's going to send over one of them is
the device identifier the device
identifiers often going to be either the
user's name or the device hostname
another item is going to be the service
name the service name is often going to
be the name of the application for
instance if you have a game called
replica island that you want to play
with other users over the network and
replica island has a network service
discovery built in the service name is
probably going to be something like
replica island another item is going to
be the host address which you don't
actually have to enter yourself a
runtime Android we'll just figure that
out for you and send that along in the
MSD packets the final item is going to
be the port and I want to do make a
certain special note about the port
which is that for for mobile
applications the easiest thing to do
when you're designing the game or the
application is not actually to pick your
own port at runtime or hard code one in
what you want to do is get a server
socket and set it to port 0 and what
that's going to do is it's going to tell
the android framework just give me
whatever port is available on on the
system when the server soccer returns
the port number two you then enter that
port number into the network service
discovery broadcasts the handy thing
about this is that if you for instance
had decided that you wanted port 53 to
be the one your application runs on and
some other application developer decided
that they wanted port 53 is the one that
there
location runs on there would never be a
conflict and there would never be an
issue where these are had to choose
between your application or someone
else's application running at any given
time right it's a nice that effect it
means you don't have to request a
reserve to port from the IAEA right now
you do still have to go and register
your service name but it's as simple as
just filling out a simple form and the
chances there being a conflict are
pretty much non-existent yeah very small
you don't actually need the IAEA a
reservation for when you're doing
internal testing but as soon as you let
your application out onto the internet
to roam free it's a really good idea to
get a registry yes it's just good
practice yeah all right now we talked a
bit earlier about Bluetooth and even
though you can't use an SD on Bluetooth
there's another answer that we want to
give you a better answer and that's
called Wi-Fi direct Wi-Fi direct is a
peer-to-peer version of Wi-Fi so unless
devices communicate with one another
without having to go through an access
point this provides many the same
benefits as Bluetooth device device
connections but with the advantage of
Wi-Fi which means increased speed and
increased range this is available on
devices running Android 40 or above
that's honeycomb and if you happen to be
running Android 4.1 jelly bean you also
get service discovery now unlike the
traditional case of network service
discovery which we just addressed Wi-Fi
direct service discovery will work even
when you're not connected to a network
so think about that for a second devices
running your application nearby can be
detected even if they're not connected
to the same network as you that's pretty
cool yeah
what uh my favorite thing about that
what that basically means as if you're
in a movie theater waiting for the
previews to start let's say you know
gone to the midnight showing or
something like that you have an hour to
kill you can open up the application and
see who else in the feet are in line is
playing the same game you are and
connect to them and play a game having
no idea who they are it gives me a
physical proximity right physical
proximity which is awesome because you
know that the what that the movie
theater is not going to have a Wi-Fi
network there and there they're probably
a lot of them these days actually are
designed to block incoming calls and
signals and stuff yeah but please don't
use that excuse to play the game right
during the movie right don't play during
the movie there's lots of helpful
pretties I tell you that's just a bad
idea and it's rude there would be a
bright screen and in front of the people
behind you and we're not suggesting that
but when you have time to kill in line
or before the previews knock yourself
out now we do want to point out that
it's still important to implement
network service discovery for when
you're connected to a network there's a
couple reasons for this one of them is
that Wi-Fi direct is not going to work
at all when you're connected to a
network because of the way the
underlying technology works either
connected to a network or you're surfing
around for Wi-Fi direct devices the
other item is that there are a lot of
services and hardware that broadcast
services that are designed to be
discovered on a network examples of this
are network cameras and network printers
now o most companies will not set up
their network printers to be Wi-Fi
direct accessible because that means
anyone who is within physical proximity
who didn't necessarily have permission
to use that printer could print out
whatever they wanted so that so being on
the network and requiring the user to be
on the network provides a a sort of
permission system or just a small layer
of security so really your best option
is to implement both Wi-Fi direct and
NSD and that way your application will
have the best of both worlds and
increase the chances of your users being
able to connect to each other no matter
what circumstance in order to use Wi-Fi
direct service discovery the the
necessary class that you want to use is
Wi-Fi p2p manager
which provides an implementation of DNS
SD similar to the way standard NSD does
for more information about how to
actually implement network service
discovery and service discovery over
Wi-Fi direct we have a training class
available at developer.android.com /
training and we really recommend you go
there and read to the tutorial we also
provide some sample code and and it
walks you through a real world example
of how to implement this functionality
in a pre-existing application and if you
have any questions about either NSD or
Wi-Fi direct join us via hangout after
the live broadcast we will be able to
help answer those questions for you
right and if you have any questions for
next week's broadcast post them to stack
overflow or send them to us via android
developers at Google+ and we'll pick the
best of them for next week's podcast
right and with that we'll see you all
next week thanks for joining us bye guys
alright and we're back to the live show
hopefully those of you watching us live
enjoyed that if you are here with us
live feel free to hop on to our Google+
hangout you can find a link by going to
developers.google.com/live clicking on
the office hours link and we'll be a
bright red hangout button feel free to
hop on and let us know what you thought
or if you have any questions about
either network service discovery or
Wi-Fi direct we'd love to take them out
too we have just a few questions in
moderator this week so if you do want to
join us on google+ act quickly we're
going to go ahead and go through the
pre-recorded or the pre submitted
moderator questions only way two people
to join us so let's go ahead and go to
the first matter question which a little
difficult that we hear but oh so this is
a question regarding Android camp and
CSS I which is the computer science
Summer Institute Institute it's a video
question and we tried to play it this
morning was actually a private video
sound of a play now let's give it a shot
just in case
ah it's playing I think hey guys aha I
was wondering if you could answer some
questions about Android this is a tot
there this summer or something but I was
wondering if the high school senior
could apply to Android camp I know that
sounds a bit strange but I I'm
developing the current an Android app
currently I'm really interested in
learning ok I assume that was that sure
the entire day the question didn't get
cut off but yeah so the question is so
for Android camp which is a program we
hold I believe once a year for
innovations our students to come and
learn a bit about android development so
the question is can high school students
apply do it so it normally is targeted
towards university students because we
expect a fairly deep knowledge of
computer programming in general it's a
pretty fast pace course so we don't have
a lot of time to go over the basics but
that being said if you think you have a
pretty solid programming background it
can keep up feel free to apply no
guarantees of course but you know yeah
you know just be sure to explain in
detail what your programming background
is and you make sure the people who are
viewing the applications know that you
can keep up now that said there's
usually if you're not in college yet
there might be some additional copy it's
about being under 18 but I'm not sure
about the legalities of that since I'm
on that program basically go ahead and
submit your answer or so submit anyway
worst case that happens is you get
turned down and you can always apply
next year but you know we certainly love
people to apply so give it a shot all
right let's move on to the next
moderator question which asks we are
creating a layered structure consisting
of a horizontal scroll view that holds a
linear layout they'll hold any number of
textfree children the number of content
is only known at run time we want all
the children to be of equal with
matching the widest how oh boy so this
question must have gotten in there
minutes ago literally because we checked
all the questions from the show and this
was not there so is that a horizontal
scrolling list view yes it yes
or ugly scrolling list view with a
linear layout containing textfree
children so basically it's a horribly
scrolling or gift of tax not list view
but scrolling okay yes so that's a
really good question because you don't
have any of this at or you don't have
any this until runtime now I what I
totally do in this case is when pretty
much any of you gets laid out there's a
measure a measure children method call
and so if you override that you can
modify the semantics about how
everything is measured and if you need
you can either go and force that to
return a specific measurement or you
could go and actually affect your list
of children at that time so this will
get called at runtime but you can fetch
your children then and make sure you
know exactly what the correct item with
this for your list view and so that way
if the default behavior is not giving
you what you want you have a chance to
modify it so yes search for measure
children and the arguments that should
be a height spec in a width spec which
is also very interesting class because
it's actually an integer by there's a
create create measure spec method that
you want to use to go and create those
yes if there's a class is maybe two
classes an integer you have height
spectrum with class and with spice spec
and inspector I came in time hi
expecting with spec with which are
integers but they're not normal integers
they're actually there's a special code
with the waste laid out so you always
want to use creative you spec when you
whenever you aren't opening those but
anyway take a look at the measure chart
measure children method and that should
give you all the details need to go and
override that behavior that's much
better than my answer which was this
going to be at a bunch of white space to
your text until it's all the same width
actually I don't even know that that
would work because it might just it
would have to be a monospaced font and I
might trim one doing the measuring
anyway all right so let's move on to the
next question is there way my app can be
notified when it's uninstalled via some
type of callback URL or broadcast I need
to be able to delete or
register majors from the cloud wow this
one also is a last minute or less two
questions thank you for the question
Alex do you want take this one sure so
there is no it there is no flag or
there's no broadcast that's going to
happen one your app gets uninstalled the
issue there is that there would be some
security implications to code running as
soon as it's uninstalled especially
especially for malicious apps like
obviously like I'm not implying your app
as much as but it's a consideration we
have to take into account however in
with in the case of wanting to
deregister and remove users from your
database in the cloud there's a couple
different things that are first of all
the person might be uninstalling on one
device but not necessarily from all of
their devices so depending on how much
space the individual is taking up this
might not be the right approach to to
keeping your database clean what you can
do like other options would include you
know matically moving for an activity
after a year or one option is actually
to use Google Cloud messaging GCM and
what you could do there is periodically
send you know still alive messages
basically two devices where your app is
installed no I actually have a better
idea in that cannot beat yeah and in
that case there's really no need to use
GCM you could just have an alarm manager
hook that says okay you know once a day
or once a week just wake up and send
this pink to my server I mean they're
not sure a lot of your way to use GCM in
that case that's her today I usually
like to say GCM is really good when you
have unplanned events so say in this
message comes in or you're a device
administrator telling the device it
should wipe itself right I mean these
aren't things you can account for and so
that's where GCM really shines but it's
just something that you know should
happen once a day or once a week you
know don't go with overhead of GC I'm
just use alarm manager right that's true
yeah k SQ mine to every time you send a
push message to a phone its additional
network traffic on our end is initial
server overhead on your end as a
developer and on top of that you know it
uses a battery
necessarily perhaps that's true my mind
went to GCN because we get this question
a lot with GCM users I don't want to be
continuously sending messages to someone
who doesn't even have the app installed
yeah that brings up another good
question though and so how does GCM
handle this right if you uninstall an
app that uses GCM how does GCM know that
that app no longer exists I mean it's
the exact same problem I suspect whoever
asked this question is probably just
trying to solve but and the answer is
actually that we don't know when you
uninstall an app again there's no way to
unregister it so what'll happen is the
very next time you send a GCM or CT diem
message to the device it'll try and
deliver it the delivery will fail and at
that point we mark the device is
unregistered and if you try any more
messages after that then you'll actually
get a failure on the server end as well
right oh it's very much a lazy
deregistration once we realize the
device just doesn't exist and we can't
address it anymore yeah so yeah even
internally we you know we run into those
same security considerations and have to
walk around them but at the end result I
don't think is actually any worse of a
user experience it still looks exactly
as it should yeah so the i guess the
summary would be others there's no way
to receive a message when the app is
uninstalled you can send a heartbeat
from your app and then assume it's been
uninstalled as soon as you stop
receiving the heartbeat but a single
uninstall by itself depending on the
context of your application of course
the uninstall by itself might not be a
good enough reason to deregister the
user and wipe their data from your
database as they may just be switching
devices or you know letting someone else
borrow the device and don't want to have
access to the personal data availability
of the person or or you know flashing
the device upgrading to a different
device there's all sorts of scenarios
where you might not want to wipe their
data just because they temper because
the app is at least temporarily
uninstalled so a timeout period like six
months or a year or something clearly
defined to the user when they set up an
account probably a better way to go yep
now if you do decide to enter
implement the heartbeat one plea please
please please don't make it more than
I'd say once a day I think would be
better for something like this I'm even
once a week maybe once a day is
reasonable the reason I mentioned that
is again battery life every time you
have alarmmanager wake the phone up or
you send a GCM message to phone the CPU
has to run the word you has to wake up
it actually on the whole ends up
consuming a lot of battery life you know
what one particular makeups not bad if
you're waking the phone up every hour
every five minutes it adds up very fast
you know every time you wake the phone
up just remember there is a cost to keep
it to a minimum for your own user sake
yeah oh it actually go so far as to say
it's possible to design your app such
that like if you're sending out other
network data like let's say you're using
a web browser or something like that you
know the device is already awake you
know the radio is already on take that
opportunity to send the heartbeat at
that point even if it's more than once a
day because that way you know that
you're not waking the phone up you're
not turning on the right a lanyard and
you're basically in no way affecting the
users battery life alright so actually
move on to the next question yeah sure
alright so the next question comes from
Terrance in Vancouver is there any way
to query information about the LTE cell
tower the device is connected to things
like MCC that's mobile country code MNC
mobile network code ECI and tak of which
actually to be honest I can't remember
what they stand for off the top of my
head so there is a telephony manager
class which will tell you I know
definitely will tell you the MCC and MNC
I can't remember och the other two will
also tell you other things like these
you know the users imei
and the equivalent which imei is a
mobile identifier I forgot yet but
basically I think risings as any ID yes
that's nice yeah so I think it's still
the same method call it'll be like get
imei or get get device ID here are a lot
of three and four letter acronyms
associated with this they are but yes
it's all inside of this telephony
manager class the one thing I will warn
you is to get access to a lot of those
values requires the access phone state
permission which display is a very scary
warning to users so for that reason I
usually like to recommend not access in
these fields unless you really really
need to do it if you're just looking for
a way to identify the user usually are
our recommendation is to just create a
random uuid on first boot stored inside
of a shared preference file and then
read from that if you really do need
something that's not out specific but
device-specific there's also a android
get secure ID method call that you can
use which is generated the very first
time user start up the phone though
there are i believe way prior to i want
to say prior to android is a 20 i think
there were some bugs in it that you have
to be aware of on certain devices i
think i was proud of froyo yes video
yeah I mean it's said something is ready
to keep in mind but there are still a
few devices out there that that
particular method call we use well we'll
run into so again for that reason we
usually like to recommend using a per
application ID rather than per device no
that is it's better for users privacy
people don't like being tracked if they
if they don't really need to write but
that said if it's the core purpose of
your application like 11 that I would I
could think of that would make good use
of this is I've seen sort of community
generated reception maps where it's you
know on a given carrier like how good is
my reception like here which is here on
that they basically the application does
that by having a few hundred thousand
people download it and it distracts GPS
and signal strength and nearby cell
towers for every user and uploads into a
central database so for something like
that obviously you want to access this
stuff and it's going to make sense when
the user looks of the permission oh
they're accessing this information on my
phone tell us what it work in which case
it would be fine
if however you're making a flashlight
app it's going to look really scary like
you're doing something really sketchy
yeah it's right yeah so I think though
yeah that is definitely a really good
use and again if you do need to access
that kind of data to lofty manager at
the classroom hood so before we move on
let's take a look at hang out see if
anybody is joining us live here ah we do
have a couple of people live so if
anybody is does want to speak life we're
go ahead and unmute the mic now feel
free to wave and speak up and you'll be
on the show with us hello I have a
question right we have one person do we
have audio yes right your microphone
should be on you might need to unmute
yourself okay my microphone is on all
right we see you we definitely do see
you but we're not sure anything oh oh
that we have both of the audio channels
near all right try talking one more time
and your luck hello ah yes we got you
okay um my I have a follow-up to the
Android cam question yeah sure I for the
for the CSS for the CSS I like Google
Computer Science Institute would you get
any preference over suit that for
students to with programming experience
over those without generally speaking we
do you know if you have a bit more
background it certainly looks better but
that being said that from what i
remember at the computer science summer
to do that one's a little bit more basic
than android camp right yeah that one I
think was more geared toward people with
little to no programming experience
whereas Android camp is geared more to
people with strong programming
background ready right but I mean I that
being said if you do have something to
show to demonstrate interest right that
always will help your application but
especially in that case where we're not
expecting as high of our as you would
for something like Android camp okay
thank you publisher
all right any other live questions I see
at least two more people on the camera
with us oh go ahead hit the chat button
they might be typing to us I realized it
ah so we're sorry we're just reading the
content to chat questions now you have
to forgive us we normally have a
computer screen in front of us but
Daniel Pham our usual engineer is
traveling in London right now and took
the studio laptop with them no
additional ish no additional questions
all right um so yeah what will still be
around here if anybody else is watching
live and wants to join us for your
hangout once again go to google.com / la
torre developers.google.com / live click
on the office hours link and there's a
join hangout button we'd love to take
questions on the air and we'll be
hanging around until we run out of
questions on moderator so let's jump
back to moderator alright so the next
question comes from I think that's is
that Nick be in Amsterdam you have to
forgive me if I'm inspiron see me his
name here my unpopular question below
slightly restated since fifty percent of
the Android devices run API ten to a
come to Google steps I'm assume that
means that the steps we publish on
developer android com what does it mean
if you encounter a bug like the one I
cited below are those bugs still being
fixed what about version numbers and so
going down to questions to that I think
the question is referring to the binding
JavaScript code to Android good feature
is buggy on Android version 2 3 will
this be fixed alright um that's a good
question and I think it's actually one
there's sometimes some confusion about
so generally speaking most of our
development efforts does go into the
latest Android version so we is very
rare for us to go and fix a bug in older
Android versions it's usually only if
there's a security issue that will issue
an update I mean even then it takes to
offer those fixes to propagate to
devices because OEMs have to go and
create a new OS build and has to get
certain
carriers so generally speaking any tiny
bug fixes that aren't absolutely
critical which means they're not
security issues are only going to be
addressed in a in the latest version of
Android so I know that's probably not
what you want to hear and I apologize
for that but that's sort of the nature
of the way Android updates working is we
really don't have a good way to go and
update those older devices reliably yeah
it also another factor is uh whether
it's a carrier managed device orses a
Nexus device right Sonny neither even if
we did go back and you know fix a bug
and gingerbread it could it could be
several months depending on which
carrier which are which manufacturer
that's why i say intergrating is going
free to you exactly and it needs to get
certified by the carriers there's a lot
of moving parts unlike you know
application development for you push it
to google play and it goes live the
timeline from you when we make a change
in code to the time it can actually get
on a handset is actually pretty long
there's a lot of certifications that
happen there's a lot of you know QA
there's you have to go get approvals
it's quite a process you know we try and
get devices out to the devices we manage
as quickly as possible you know some OEM
s and some carriers are better than
others but in general we do try and get
those updates to the phones as quickly I
think everybody in the ecosystem tries
to get those updates out as quickly as
possible but again maybe older the phone
is the more difficult it is and you are
at least internally Google all of our
effort goes to the latest version now i
will add one last thing you know it is
possible to go in back porch changes to
older versions of android i have seen
that happen on some cases where a device
manufacturer knows that they're not
going to be able to update a phone
you're perhaps you know they're spinning
the interesting times somewhere else
where the phone just simply doesn't
support anymore I have seen cases where
a logo and back port that one particular
change without doing a complete OS
update so it is possible but I'd say
it's more rare in order for that to
happen also has to be a better that's
big enough to actually get the OEMs
attention right that at that point it
also becomes confusing as a developer
because then the there's no way to sort
of shoehorn in an SDK version between
like in this case it would be between 10
and 11 the SDK versions and integers so
we can't a day you know 10.5 for the
version of gingerbread that has this
thing fixed and then and then if you
really strapped assuming that this
particular bug was fixed it would go to
you know if half of the gingerbread
devices have happened on the half that
didn't you wouldn't really necessarily
be able to distinguish between devices
where your code worked and devices where
it didn't so in the long run they
wouldn't actually probably help all that
much all right so hopefully that
answered question let's move on to the
last moderator question this one comes
from Jay Dixon in Perth Australia who
says we support a benevolent
organization who which is to donate
in-app purchases content to his
customers which are their users right
they wish to pay the purchase price
however they can't see a way to do that
in Google Play is there a way to do this
so Alex you want to take this one sure
so there's no fine grain solution in
terms of purchasing specific apps for a
on the behalf of a different account
what you can do however is by google
play gift cards and give those to the
users obviously this this isn't ideal in
that it has a certain lack of control on
that you know if said customers are you
know fourth graders or something like
that there's a chance that instead of
buying the awesome note taking app
they're going to spend it on Angry Birds
but but it's still an option and you can
you can get them I want to say in
increments of like 20 25 bucks something
like that I that's the way I would go
yeah so I not not the best solution but
unfortunately it's the only one we have
available yeah it's the it's the current
solution hello right so let's switch
back to moderate or sorry to hang us one
more time if there's any other live
questions we'll go ahead and take those
now
anybody on live questions who wishes to
ask or something icic three people there
there's one question okay so there's a
text question from David Cox it was a
little unclear from the video but is it
possible to use n SD and query services
over Wi-Fi direct at the same time so
yeah that's that's entirely possible NSD
will work over any any TCP connection
and Wi-Fi direct is it is a TCP
connection so normally what you do is
you use actually they work pretty well
together for that because of floats the
nature wife hide yo wife a direct has an
implementation of NS d I'm essentially
they broadcast the service information
so as wife at like as part of the Wi-Fi
discovery but right before you're even
connected we do get into a bit of
buzzard collision here yeah there's a
bit of confusion in that there's network
service discovery works over a network
it's find everything that's on the same
network as you are separately from that
there's service discovery over Wi-Fi
direct which is find stuff when you're
not connected to a network now the when
NSD comes into play is if you use Wi-Fi
direct and you then connect to a network
or so I use Wi-Fi direct to sort of
create an ad hoc network between a bunch
of different devices at that point n SD
network service discovery comes into
effect because there's a network for it
to work on right so Wi-Fi Wi-Fi direct
will help you find other devices in
proximity right that could that you know
say they support your app they'll
connect to them via Wi-Fi direct and
then you'll use NSD the proper nst that
we address to the begin the video to go
and find everything once you're
connected right which also a work
outside of Wi-Fi direct if you're on a
normal regular Wi-Fi network you use the
same NSD crypt all right so hopefully
that answers your question so if you do
have any more questions about that just
let us know next question from Terrence
to you says is there any way to query
information about the LTE cell tower the
device is connected to some things like
MCC MSC
cetera we actually answered this earlier
I don't know if you missed the answer
and off so they are oh you unless you
want to know the specific cell tower the
answer is yes all that should be
contained in the cleft a manager class
unfortunately can't tell you the exact
method names off the top of my head but
there is a way to go and get a list of
the cell towers they're in range there's
a way to go and query the active cell
tower I will say that the MTC and MNC
are not typically actually no to this
what properties a cell tower what am I
thinking but they're also properties of
the sim card so you have to watch out
for that I'm really impressed you know
all this off the top of your head by now
that there's ways to go and query all of
that you can get it for this current sim
card you can get it for the current
power all that should be contained
inside of the lefty manager class if you
dig around in there you'll find all the
data you're looking for all right any
other live questions either via chat or
via if you have a webcam and microphone
you can help on life too I'm taking the
silence as a lack of questions so at
this point I'm going to say that's it
for this week if you do have arshad one
last thing before we close let us know
what you thought about the new format
earlier than the deer android show i
think it worked pretty well but of
course we care a lot about what our
viewers think too so if you thought it
was if you thought you liked it let us
know in the youtube comments if you
hated it let us know in youtube comment
and assuming people liked it i think we
might keep doing something like that in
the future and if they hate it will to
sue assume because it's you know YouTube
comments it's true it's true i jus de
pomme bitch already love it painful
right anyway it was awesome chatting
with you all this week be sure to send
us in your Android development questions
either via moderator or also just go
ahead and plus us on on Android
developers to will be taking a look over
the next couple days for the next
question answer for the next dear
Android segment we'll pick the best ones
and we'll join you again next week
wednesday 2 p.m. pacific cool right and
one last thing thanks to Louis gray who
is our producer this week for valiantly
stepping in and keeping the show running
so thank you
so much All Right see y'all next week